what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we're gonna be dangerous we are
going to cover the original Watchmen
comic and Doomsday Clock at the same
time and I don't know why I think this
is a good idea but I think it is I think
it's a good idea now we did part one a
while ago and people were asking worst
watchman part two honestly I was waiting
for Doomsday Clock to drop because it
seems like it'd be the only time to
cover it's like infinity war right like
infinity war the best time to cover it
is when everybody's searching for it
when the movie comes out now with
regards to the first Watchmen comic the
first one of the things we talked about
was that it was laying the groundwork in
a lot of ways for the characters who
they are what they were doing we really
followed Rorschach different things like
that issue number two I think is
probably one like the defining parts of
the comic because what it focuses on is
the idea of who the characters are as
individuals and that's the cool thing
because when it comes to Alan Moore's
Watchmen it's not like a traditional
superhero comic that you read right now
and the first comic we talked about it
was the death of the comedian and that's
what set in motion the idea of Rorschach
trying to find out who killed a comedian
and so that's what set us on this path
of everything that goes on in this
particular story but with the death of
Eddie Blake there are a myriad of things
going on when it comes to Silk Spectre
you know for example visiting her mother
in a lot of ways if you watch the movie
it was the whole idea of her mom was
just kind of like hey you don't
understand what the world is like and
you know it's if so Spectre just got to
be like yeah I do understand what it's
like and you know so on and so forth but
the cool thing about this is that it's
not necessarily just Sally Jupiter's
just fighting with her daughter it's
this whole idea of the nature of people
when you have sadly Jupiter arguing with
her daughter and the whole idea is that
Sally Jupiter is kind of showing her
daughter the fact that people sent her
pinups and they send like you know
artistic drawings and things like that
Sally Jupiter's actually welcoming to it
were her daughters more like that's
disgusting that's basically people with
sitting you images that shouldn't be
considered flattering because it's more
insulting than anything else
but it's two different ideologies that
are conflicting with one another when it
comes to Sally Jupiter she's kind of old
hat with regards to how she abused
herself and how she used the world in
her mind it is considered to be a
flattering thing because really in a lot
of ways she's kind of living in the past
she's sort of surrounded by this
nostalgia she used to be a superhero
once you know she was super attractive
in her youth you know really kind of
appealing to these ideas people who say
look man you were gorgeous back in the
day surrounds herself with a sword of
adoration that she used to get but
doesn't get anymore
and that's the nature of people we as
people in a lot of ways look to the past
we look to where things used to be kind
of looking to a better day so on and so
forth it was kind of cool but with Silk
Spectre herself she's more of a
generation of empowerment where this
kind of thing is more demeaning than
anything else people shouldn't
necessarily be defined by how it is that
they look but on the other side of the
equation so expect errs not without her
faults and her mom points this out her
mom's like look the only reason why
you're paired up with dr. Manhattan it's
so basically just sleep with him is to
keep him quote/unquote comfortable and
that's the crazy thing about this is
because in some ways it's true and
actually we're gonna see that a whole
dynamic to a degree begin to unfold but
something that I want to point out here
is that while you know Silk Spectre is
sort of ranting and raving to her mom
about all these things one of the things
that happens we sort of get this
flashback to the idea or Eddie Blake who
tried to force himself onto Sally
Jupiter now of course a lot of people
remember this from the movie and it is
kind of a strange scenario because this
is one of those situations where her mom
argues that the world's not necessarily
as black and white as her daughter would
like to believe you know we're so
expected would like to believe there's
good guys or bad guys done everything's
copacetic for the most part the idea of
a Sally Jupiter is saying but it's not
that way it's wisdom versus youth it is
there's there's black there's white and
then there's all the shades in between
and emotions only make things even more
complicated than that will you have some
more like Eddie Blake who forces himself
onto Sally Sally Jupiter at that point
it becomes about power and with Eddie
Blake being as unstable as you seem to
be in a lot of ways then it's not
necessarily a thing of oh my god I can't
believe he did that to me at this point
it puts Sally Jupiter in a state of fear
for the most part and that sets the
stage for things that come later on down
the line but again moving through this
whole idea of going into that - the
concept of people in general in terms of
how they function the various members of
the watchmen this switches over to
really one of the first major meetings
is a flashback from Ozymandias with the
Watchmen group as a whole everybody's
sort of looking around and paying
attention and seeing what's going on
whereas you have Eddie Blake who's just
sort of blowing it all off and that's
the funny thing people really in a lot
of ways looked at Eddie Blake as a guy
who was just a total jerk not
necessarily when it came to the
character of Eddie Blake his whole
philosophy was that the world is just
kind of a joke that people are who they
are that they're flawed they're screwed
up that they're messed up but the only
way to really maintain your sanity the
only way to really function is to just
kind of laugh at it and that's why he
says this whole idea of the Watchmen is
nonsense because you're not gonna change
the hearts and
of people if people wanted to change
they would have changed already and so
instead it's the Watchmen just kind of
coming together and fighting this futile
fight there's a bunch of people running
around in masks thinking they can change
the world when in actuality they can't
putting on costumes dressing up as
superheroes and fighting crime doesn't
change anything it takes the
responsibility off of traditional people
and puts it on the shoulders of those
who are willing to take up costumes and
so again switching over to dr. Manhattan
we jump to basically the whole Vietnam
conflict Eddie Blake and dr. Manhattan
in a bar you know coming at the war's
close and the whole idea here is that
again he seems to be almost like a
sociopath in this particular instance
you know some pregnant woman walks up
you know Hey look the child's yours and
his idea is it ain't mine I don't care
I'm leaving this place
it doesn't matter and that's what's so
crazy about his character is he seems so
removed from traditional society so
removed from people that he doesn't even
care that he has a child we find this
out because once he insults this girl
she slashes him across the face of the
bottle he shoots her in the head and
Miss breeze into sharp fruition not only
the nature of dr. Manhattan but the
nature of Eddie Blake himself in this
sense that were any Blake's just kind of
like look I'm leaving this place I don't
care like you were a means to an end who
cares what happens to you the crazy
thing is that dr. Manhattan it's almost
the exact same way that's the whole case
that Eddie Blake makes to Manhattan when
that happens like you just you gunned
down a pregnant woman he's like yeah and
you could have done anything to stop me
you could have done any number of things
to keep this from happening but you
didn't and that's the nature of dr.
Manhattan within the realm of the
Watchmen dr. Manhattan views the world
in the Watchmen universe in relation to
himself you know Manhattan's like I'm
more powerful than any being that could
ever exist I can wipe out the world if I
wanted to for him watching humanity go
about its musings and meandering around
doing whatever is it a dust would be
like you concerning yourselves with an
anthill of what difference is this serve
and that's how dr. Manhattan views
people they're insignificant they're
unimportant and so again this goes on
into the nature of Eddie Blake when we
pick up with night owl we pick up with
the the all these protests and things
like that and Eddie Blake's response to
it when Eddie Blake looks at people he's
just like you don't do anything of any
real measure of any real note and this
this really comes into sharp relief when
he jumps into a crowd and starts firing
on people yeah because the whole idea is
yeah people are all about changing
things until it gets too dangerous
and then you
want to run like you want to diss run
away and run away and let somebody else
solve the problem that's the nature of
this whole thing that's the philosophy
of it all that's why I say Alan Moore's
Watchmen is really intriguing because
the whole story is basically a
philosophical critique on normal society
if these protesters really believed in
what they were protesting they'd give
their lives for it but they don't
they're protesting only so far is it's
easy to do you know and so again that's
the crazy thing about all this is it's a
critique of society and so ultimately
this all boils down to the idea of were
shacked watching all these events unfold
keeping an eye on everything that's
going on but for him one of the first
things he does is he basically tracks
down Moloch now of course Moloch was a
guy that had faced off against you know
comedian on several occasions back when
they were younger the problem with this
is that Moloch is basically dying but
one of the things that he talks about is
that Eddie Blake had basically come to
visit him and Eddie Blake was basically
losing his mind he was rambling on you
know referring to it all being a joke
and so on and so forth and again that's
how this works
Eddie Blake was looking at humanity and
saying dude it's all a joke it's all
just some crazy joke but he's not
talking about man this is just so funny
and humanity's just so screwed you know
it was weird for him he's learned
something he's learned that a plan is in
the works
and that's how he cokes referring to it
as a joke referring to it as being silly
laughing at it is how he deals with the
nature of the world and that is the core
principle of the nature of the comedian
he laughs about every problem that he
has you could take this exact same
philosophy and like apply to the Joker
and you could fly to the early days of
the Joker so much backstory and so much
involvement has been done that Joker
over the years that he's almost nothing
like the comedian but you know in the
early days when he was still somewhat of
an enigma you could apply that concept
to him it's just how he copes but the
way the comedian deals with things is
the way that people deal with things
there's kind of the idea that people
deal with things by not necessarily
facing them in a lot of ways that if I
laugh at it if I consider it a joke and
I can maintain my sanity in a world that
is otherwise gone mad that's filled with
hypocritical people crooked politicians
the whole nine yards the crazy thing
about this is that in this meeting that
he has with Moloch basically sort of
losing his mind it's almost like he's
rethinking his life philosophy because
of what he's learned what's what's so
funny about all this what's so hilarious
about all this it's basically just sort
of like this mental breakdown you know
he runs over all the things that he's
done heinous things to kids he's done
heinous things to women things that he
regrets but for him it didn't seem to
matter
at the time anyway because he was just
blending in with a mad world so it
didn't really matter but having seen
what he's seen it gives him pause for
thought what kind of world are we living
in where this sort of thing is okay and
with what's coming later on down the
line with what he knows you can't stop
how's the world gonna cope and so of
course with Rorschach basically getting
the last little tidbits of the story and
basically bailing out one of the things
that he does is he goes back and he
visits the grave of Eddie Blake now this
is one of the coolest parts of the story
I think this monologue of Rorschach that
goes on here because one of the things
that he does is he gives us like his
insight into the world in a lot of ways
and he did that in the first part you
know and he'll do that over the course
of the story where Eddie Blake copes
with the world by basically saying yeah
the world's mad but the only way to
really deal with it is to just laugh at
it for war Shaq it's not really a
laughing matter he's just kind of like
this is how the world is
he's very cynical in that regard in the
sense people are just bad people are
inherently bad but that's just the
nature of people this eventual breakdown
of society that's quote-unquote end of
all things that's gonna happen because
people are just like that people just do
bad things it's just the nature of
people he accepts that all he sees is
the negativity in the world and so when
he goes and he looks at the grave of
Eddie Blake he gives us a sort of
monologue that you know is this really
what what the destiny awaits for
everybody who's part of the Watchmen for
everybody who does what they do is it
just the nature of who they are is it
just the idea that their actions will
always bring violence is there something
in their personality that invites that
kind of violence this is just the nature
of who they are as people and so it's
incredibly well done because what he
says is that Eddie Blake understood that
the nature of people is violent but the
only way for him to deal with it we
should just kind of make a joke out of
it to laugh at it but in his mind and
the mind of Eddie Blake Blake saw the
nature of people and he decided to
become a parody of it to become a
mockery of it that's why he was so
violent that in his mind if humanity is
going to be this incredibly terrible the
only way to cope with that is to laugh
about it maybe that's just the way this
goes maybe this is the fate that
inevitably awaits us all you know maybe
dr. Manhattan will find his in in some
form or fashion assuming somebody can
pull it off
so expect her Nite Owl Rorschach himself
it's the end that they all wait for it
and it makes sense because if you go
back and you look at the members of the
Minutemen most all of them met their end
in a pretty gruesome way I mean Mothman
was thrown in an insane asylum policy
Mason made it out and you know Sally
Jupiter kind of made it out to a degree
but it's not like they made it out and
they were
liberated by humanity it's not like
Sally Jupiter you know finished her
tenure as a superhero and humanity was
like all right you're gonna be set up in
the most lavish of places that could
ever exist and we're gonna make sure
that you never want for anything in your
whole life she's just living in some
retirement community upstate somewhere
people look at her is like yeah she was
a hero once cool and that's it one of
two fates awaits us either it's just
some grisly death of the hands of some
villain somewhere who's going around
sniffing out Watchmen or meandering
throughout the rest of our lives and
then that's really about it there's no
great story to be told but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]